oh yeah this feel good it feel good tell  us about the performance tonight I'm  playing two songs in full no edits  really excited  [Music]  [Applause]  I've been asking everybody who are you  so excited to see a lot of people been  saying you so who are you excited to  think I just saw knows a little like  kids dressed up like they're in Oliver  Twist and I think they're in Katie's  performance so I'm excited to see that  now I've been listening to the album all  weekend one thing I noticed you drunk a  lot about your family in this album  which I love without a conscious  decision do you know what I just all of  my other albums have been about  heartbreak and I'm just not in that  place and I have to find new things to  write about and yeah I just guess well  done my family of it  [Music]  you